[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a british comic science
fiction film called faq about time
travel spoilers ahead watch out and take
care
at the start of the movie we are
introduced to three friends ray pete and
toby who are enjoying some drinks in a
pub they talk about some interesting
topics like movies and time travel while
also having some good debates after a
while pete decides to head to the toilet
he has a very intricate way of peeing
which involves a bit of singing and
dancing after he's done he heads outside
but as soon as he opens the door he
finds everyone dead on the floor with
devastation lying all around suddenly he
also notices a beardier version of
himself which is his future self and
rushes back into the toilet after a bit
of contemplating he returns to the bar
again but this time it has reverted back
to its normal self following this we are
taken six hours before the incident
somewhere in space astronaut ray talks
about time travel from one of the
spaceships floating around he seems to
be briefing a large audience on how one
can combat against the aliens and
destroy their existence slowly he gets
over excited about the mission and
starts spewing profanity when the camera
pans to his audience it turns out that
they're just a bunch of kids who are
there for a science program in fact the
whole setup is inside a kid's park as
soon as rey finishes his overly
energetic speech the kids start crying
he tries to calm them down by turning on
the alert button but it only makes the
situation worse just then the manager of
the park enters the room and witnesses
the commotion enraged he calls rey
inside his office and strips him of his
duties ray even has his handshake
snubbed by his manager and in a fit of
rage he kicks one of the toys in his
room however when the manager stares at
him he quickly picks it up as if nothing
happened here we get to know that rey is
a nerd who loves everything about time
travel and sci-fi outside pete and toby
are dressed in dinosaur suits
distributing food pamphlets the two have
been struggling to get a decent job and
now have ended up at the same kids park
toby who is another nerd stresses that
they're doing the job wrong but a
no-nonsense and carefree pete assures
him that it's right while the duo is
arguing they are approached by a
distraught rey in the next scene the
group sits at a restaurant and discusses
possible job opportunities for rey pete
asks ray about his dream job if there
were no limits and the latter
immediately replies that he wants to
become a time lord hearing this pete
starts teasing rey saying that he will
never find a girl this way however rey
retorts that there are several sci-fi
loving girls out there who will
definitely find him attractive later the
guys go to a movie but they hate it toby
mentions that he can do much better than
the hollywood writers and the other two
challenge him to come up with his own
story toby accepts and takes out his
diary in which he writes all of his
ideas he then recites his story but
sadly rey and pete find it hilarious
following this the group heads to the
local pub to have some beers there the
group discusses some ideas on how they
can make movies better and toby writes
it all down in his diary after they are
done toby tears the page with all the
notes and places it on the table
meanwhile pete taunts his friends for
being nerds and reveals that he doesn't
believe in anything supernatural as the
group is discussing their drinks run out
and rey is sent to fetch more from the
counter rey gathers the drinks from the
counter and as he is about to leave a
beautiful girl named cassie calls him by
his name rey who is confused especially
because she didn't call him time lord
inquires on how she knows about him and
cassie replies that she is a time
traveling agent and visits different
time zones to repair time leaks leaks
are the glitches in time through which
normal people can venture into other
time durations without taking her words
seriously ray sarcastically asks cassie
to kill hitler but the latter replies
that it would be against the rules of
time because hitler is bussin she also
mentions that killing someone from the
past is known as editing in their terms
and doing so will create a chain
reaction that may cause grave
consequences however there are a group
of editors that kill famous people right
after their most famous work rey is
confused by the phenomenon but cassie
gives some examples in the context of da
vinci it would be killing him right
after the mona lisa and for kurt cobain
it would be killing him right after
never mind cassie mentions that her job
is to repair time leaks so that time can
flow as usual she further exclaims that
her job is fairly boring but one of the
perks is getting to meet famous people
from history like rey turns out that rey
is famous in the future because of
something he hasn't done yet she claims
that in the future several books will be
written about him and refers to him as
ray the great indicating that she is not
only a fan but has a bit of a crush on
him rey is fascinated by the information
as he has never had a girl to talk
sci-fi with they talk for a bit more and
eventually head their own ways rey
assumes that his friends set him up with
cassie to make him feel better after
losing his job however when he confronts
them about it they deny arranging
anything hence he narrates the whole
story to them but pete and toby are
having none of it after having a few
laughs pete decides to go to the toilet
again he has a very intricate way of
peeing after he's done he heads outside
but as soon as he opens the door he
finds everyone dead on the floor and
among them is his future self seeing
this he rushes back into the toilet
after a bit of contemplation he returns
to the bar again but this time it has
reverted back to its normal self he
starts explaining everything to his
friends but the guys are skeptical of
the story pete suspects that it is the
same leak that cassie was talking about
eventually after a lot of convincing
pete gets the duo to head to the toilet
and check for themselves however pete
himself is also forced to enter despite
not wanting to inside rey checks the
stalls for any pranks but doesn't find
anything pete then mentions that if they
want to travel through time they will
have to replicate his peeing routine the
trio then sings and dances together in
the most awkward way possible to make
matters worse an old man catches them in
the act but toby mentions that it's a
science project after they are done they
head outside but find everything normal
much to pete's dismay they then decide
to head towards their table but are
shocked to find their past selves from
30 minutes ago there scared the trio
immediately retreats to another room and
starts brainstorming ideas on how to
avoid the situation ray mentions that
they cannot confront their past selves
as it will create a paradox whereas pete
mentions that they cannot go back inside
the toilet as that leads to uncertainty
hence rey comes up with an idea and they
decide to head inside a cupboard until
their past selves head towards the
toilet inside rey suddenly remembers
that since they're in the past cassie is
still present in the pub after cassie
finishes talking with the past rey the
original rey approaches her and asks for
help he then reveals to her that the
leak is the toilet itself but cassie
doesn't believe it she instead walks out
the door despite rey's numerous attempts
to convince her but as soon as she goes
out she comes back inside with a totally
different appearance turns out that
cassie has been gone for six months
despite being away from rey for only one
second cassie informs rey that she has
sorted everything out and suggests he
wait with his friends inside the
cupboard until their past selves leave
meanwhile it seems as if both of them
have started liking each other in the
next scene the trio come out of the
cupboard after their past selves enter
the toilet not willing to take any risks
this time they head to the ladies toilet
to freshen up but when they come out
they are shocked to see the pub in a
post-apocalyptic state seeing this pete
decides to flee back into the women's
toilet again but when rey and toby are
about to follow him pete suddenly
emerges from the men's bathroom in a
filthy state and stops them from
entering he seems to have traveled and
stayed in another time zone for so long
that he has been severely traumatized
confused ray and toby asked him about
where he was but pete is too scared to
answer instead he keeps mentioning that
they need to be ready with food and
weapons as toby and rey wander around to
scavenge some supplies we are shown an
aerial view of the dilapidated city
which appears to be destroyed by some
kind of nuclear strike soon the trio
gathers some weapons and get changed
into new outfits after a while when they
head outside again they are taken aback
to find a large painting of themselves
on the wall turns out that all three of
them are extremely popular in the future
what's even more surprising is the fact
that they are wearing the exact same
outfits as in the painting as the three
are thinking about how they might have
become popular they suddenly hear a
strange sound they immediately rush
inside and right after a huge ant
devours a homeless man wandering outside
inside the toilet while pete is
explaining some of his scary experiences
from the future their past selves
suddenly enter the toilet pete tries to
contact them but his friends pull him
away inside one of the stalls from there
they can just watch as their past selves
make the same mistakes that they did
earlier when the past rey comes to check
on the final stall he is distracted by
the past pete hence he doesn't notice
his future selves when the past selves
leave the trio comes out of the stall
that pete is enraged that he wasn't
allowed to warn his past self hence he
rushes out of the toilet despite his
friend's disapproval when rey and toby
also venture out to find their friend
they are taken aback to see several
people dressed like them having a party
turns out that the party is a fan
knight based on the trio toby is
immediately flattered by the attention
but rey suggests he play it cool soon
they find pete and also come across
another painting of themselves there
they noticed the piece of paper that
they had used to write their ideas on
earlier and suspect it as the reason for
their fame but since they were drunk
when they were writing they cannot
remember its contents the trio tries
hard to remember the contents but just
then they are approached by another time
traveler named millie millie claims that
she is cassie's superior and assures the
group that she's there to take them back
to their own time the trio become
delighted and follow her instructions in
the next scene the group reaches the pub
once again and it now looks to be normal
their past selves are sitting in their
spot so they decide to have a couple of
beers and wait patiently after the past
selves leave the trio quickly reach
their spot and start reading the piece
of paper while the exact contents are
not mentioned the trio seems to be
stunned by it they then decide to leave
the paper on the table so that they can
get rich and famous in the future
thinking that everything is now back to
normal rey decides to take a leak but
this time he heads outside as he is
about to do his business he is again
approached by cassie who seems very
happy to see him the two bond for a
while but when ray mentions that he
traveled into the future cassie doesn't
believe him rey then explains about the
specifics of his time travel which
includes him meeting millie shocked
cassie reveals that millie is an editor
whose main job is to kill people right
after they do something famous in this
context she wants to kill ray and his
friends as they just laid the foundation
for their popularity on a piece of paper
hearing this rey heads inside to warn
his friends despite cassie telling him
that it's not safe inside rey explains
the situation to his friends and they
get ready to escape however it soon
dawns on them that millie is a time
traveler so escaping won't be of any
help just when the group seems to be
doomed rey comes up with an idea he
mentions that if they burn the piece of
paper they won't be famous in the future
and hence millie won't be after them
pete also approves of the idea but toby
is hesitant as he thinks that it's their
only chance of becoming rich despite
this rey tries to burn the paper but
unluckily the lighter doesn't work he
then heads to the counter to get another
lighter but toby gets increasingly
aggressive and starts fighting with pete
while the two are at it they are
approached by millie rey and cassie try
their best to stop her but they are
easily overpowered she even injures pete
when he tries to burn the paper by
himself just then toby comes to his
senses and tries to destroy the paper
but millie uses her superpowers to swap
the paper away and eventually destroy
the whole room in the following scene we
are shown a bloody room with bodies
lying all around the paper has also
landed on its original spot on the table
just then rey starts moving implying
that he is not dead yet pete's past self
also walks in at the same moment and
after witnessing the chaos he runs back
meanwhile rey musters up the last of his
energy and tries to grab the paper in
the process he spills beer on it causing
the contents to evaporate with the paper
destroyed the boys never become famous
and as a result the editors were never
after them because of this everything
that took place is reverted to its
original form and the boys are taken to
the same spot they were in some hours
ago finally everything seems to be
normal again in the final scene as the
trio reaches near the train tracks they
are again approached by cassie she makes
out with rey and here it is revealed
that they have been dating for the last
two years however there has been a
slight problem in the timeline and
cassie needs the boy's help to sort it
out the movie ends as cassie opens a
portal to the future and the boys jump
right in i wonder what was on that paper
probably the idea for only fans
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching